you see people still doing your
choreography and doing the renegade
answer thank you for joining me uh
amidst this crazy crazy time how you
guys are surviving has been difficult
I love Julia how easy is it to get mom
and dad to do it tick tock dance with
you though dad what's stopping you you
got to do to vegetate with the interest
meet yeah hard to get into the social
media I will do what she and I wasn't
very easy but I think I'd embarrass her
to reconcile that some kind of way you
know
you the rest of the dads of America no
time to do it I feel like now's the time
to do it honestly maybe you should do it
to the new Scoob dance
[Music]
Julia let's talk about the new tick-tock
dance that you're doing for the new
animated movie Scoob I mean what was the
inspiration behind this latest choreo
that you put together were you big
scooby-doo fan before yeah
is it a trip that like you got movie
studios now reaching out to you to do
stuff like this like that must be a good
feeling it looks effortless but I know
you do put some thought and creativity
into and I think that's why it catches
on right people love all your chick talk
videos and you're still having fun with
there right you don't feel like you're
pressure to do it well cuz you're 14
years old there's all these eyes on you
like I can't imagine I wasn't I was in a
viral tick-tock star when I was 14 years
old you know I'll have you been kind of
adjusting to you know more eyes on you
and more attention do you still feel
like I don't know a sense of pride when
you because I I just learned renegade
recently in quarantine because I have
the time and let me tell you I'm not
lying it took me four hours you see
people still doing your choreography and
doing the renegade dance like what does
that make you feel like ever since then
while you dance up the NBA all-stars
game you're just featured on the cover
of The Hollywood Reporter do you feel
like all of this attention is now kind
of validation knowing that you kind of
struggle to get that recognition for the
renegade dance yeah I mean it's really
nice for me
yeah absolutely
what's next like do you have them I
don't know maybe like a dream collab
someone you want to dance with on tik
tok once we are like safe to go out in
the world again maybe I love that why
Marseille and why Missy Missy because I
just like the way like I like the way I
like her music I like my hair jazz
videos high-energy because I just love
what tick tock is doing forever for all
kind of creatives for kids for adults
for everybody right and you like I
wanted to get your tink because the top
two songs on the Billboard Hot 100 right
now our dough Jacquet say so and Magda
stallions Savage and I feel like those
songs were really made popular because
the viola dance challenge is on tick
tock like you feel like you know your
choreography and other people's dance
moves impact on the music industry right
now everyone's into it I feel like just
scoop you up there yeah it's inevitable
I think you're gonna have to hop in one
of those videos you know Jala maybe
teach him a little 2z slide that's easy
a little drain
why should we use what advice you have
for young creators like yourself or
either starting tic toc or want to hop
on a trend what advice do you have for
them you know don't worry about how hard
it is when I challenges is just have fun
you know don't give up
[Music]